[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
normalerweise gibt es ja an einem
sonntag immer eine torte oder einem
motiv torte zwar sogar von beginn an
meines kanals schon immer so heute
machen wir das ganz anders denn heute
gibt es was herzhaftes und so habe ich
mir für heute ein kebab rezept
ausgesucht aus meinem neuen türkischen
kochbuch und zwar heißt es ellis
türkische küche und zwar gibt es da ein
rezept darin das ist mein absolutes
lieblingsrezept es nennt sich gekehrt
maikäfer und zwar ist es ein
fleischgericht und in der türkei werden
einfach alle gerichte mit fleisch kebab
genannt das heißt nicht nur der döner
kebab der dresdner hier in deutschland
bekannt ist sondern eben auch alle
anderen fleischgerichte und schippert
mit kebab das ist im prinzip ein ragout
und fleisch ragout aus rindfleisch und
dazu wird ein richtig cremiger leckerer
joghurt serviert und frittierte
kartoffeln und das ganze schmeckt so
lecker
ich habe es jetzt auch schon auf einer
messe gemacht und bei einem kochkurs
gemacht und alle waren so begeistert
heute möchte ich mit euch zusammen also
dieses rezept zubereiten und euch
gleichzeitig auch mein neues kochbuch
vorstellen ich habe das buch selbst
türkische küche genannt ihr wisst ja
wahrscheinlich dass meine eltern aus der
türkei sind und vor über 45 jahren nach
deutschland gekommen sind damals als
gastarbeiter aber natürlich haben sie im
laufe der jahre hier einfach ihre heimat
gefunden hier ihre existenz aufgebaut
und natürlich auch eine familie
gegründet
und deswegen habe ich meine türkischen
wurzeln natürlich sehr geprägt und ich
liebe die türkische küche wenig rezepte
aus der türkischen küche macher auch auf
meinem youtube kanal dann kommen oft
ganz ganz viele kommentare zb von den
griechen die dann sagen halt stopp sally
das ist kein türkisches sondern ein
griechisches rezept oder die araber
kommen und sagen nein nein das gehört zu
uns die kroaten die libanesen usw
alle sagen wie man ein ziel das gehört
nicht in die türkische küche sondern zu
uns und dem prinzip habt ihr auch alle
recht denn die türkei das ist ein
vielvölkerstaat und das ist wirklich
eine der abwechslungsreichsten küchen
der welt und das hat einfach mit der
geographischen lage und der geschichte
der türkei zu tun bevor ich jetzt aber
weiter erzähle zeige ich erstmal die
zutaten die für das heutige rezept
benötigt und ich werde das ganze jetzt
so machen die zutaten habe ich ja schon
gepostet vor einigen tagen unterstützt
gerne live mit mehr mit kochen
so in echtzeit das rezept mit kochen und
die ersten zehn die das rezept dann auf
facebook und auf instagram posten also
das werde ich am ende noch mal erklären
die bekommen dann von mir ein buch
kostenlos zugeschickt natürlich mit
widmung für das jackett mit kebab
braucht ihr 500 gramm rinderfilet oder
ohren trägt 40 gramm butter schmalz eine
zwiebel 2 knoblauchzehen eine rote spitz
paprika oder eine normale paprika eine
tomate ein paar blätter frischem
basilikum
hier habe ich noch die gewürze und sogar
ein teelöffel salz einen halben
teelöffel kreuzkümmel etwas pfeffer
einen teelöffel chili und einen
teelöffel bohnenkraut oder oregano
hier habe ich noch 800 gramm kartoffeln
vorwiegend festkochend und das geschälte
gewicht sondern 800 sein und für die
joghurt soße brauche ich noch 400 gramm
joghurt dann nehme ich gern den zehn
prozent joghurt eine knoblauchzehe einen
halben teelöffel salz und ein viertel
teelöffel pfeffer zuerst stelle ich
jetzt die joghurt soße herren und wie
gesagt nämlich da immer gerne den
zehnprozentigen joghurt weil er einfach
super cremig ist und wirklich perfekt
zum gericht passt also falls jetzt
skeptisch zeit und sagt joghurt so
fleisch passt doch gar nicht dann
probiert auf jeden fall trotzdem mann
aus denn der joghurt da muss einfach
sein
ich nehme es in joghurt und habe ich
jetzt hier die knoblauchzehe die wird
fein gerieben es mir ziemlich große zehe
daher nehme ich jetzt nur drei viertel
der rest kommt ins kaputt gericht mit
rein
[Musik]
dann macht die gewürze salz und pfeffer
wer möchte kann jetzt hier zb noch etwas
getrocknete menschen mit rein geben
ich lasse es jetzt weg denn bei mir
kommt später noch basilico mit rein ins
gericht und ich möchte auch dass der
basilikum heraussticht und jetzt einfach
kurz glatt rühren
jetzt ist die yoga-kurse schon fertig
die kann ich jetzt abdecken und einfach
kurz kühl stellen
als nächstes kommt das fleisch dran das
nehme ich jetzt hier beziehen
rinderfilet aber wie gesagt könnt ihr
auch andere kurt nehmen und da kann man
auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel falsch
machen das ist nämlich ein super zartes
fleisch und das wird jetzt in feine
streifen geschnitten
das heißt ich schneide mir zuerst einmal
scheiben runter und dann feine streifen
[Musik]
weiter geht es mit den knoblauchzehen
und der zwiebel die werden nämlich fein
gewürfelt hier in deutschland kennt man
meist nur den döner kebab was ich
ziemlich schade finde denn die türkische
küche gehört wirklich zu den
vielseitigsten küchen der welt und wie
gesagt hat das auch mit der
geographischen lage zu tun das heißt die
türkei ist also das bindeglied zwischen
europa und asien
und natürlich auch mit der geschichte
das osmanische reich war das reich der
dynastie der osmanen von etwa 1200 99
bis 1922 zur zeit seiner größten
ausdehnung im siebzehnten jahrhundert
erstreckte es sich von seinen kern
landen kleinasien und rumänien nordwärts
bis in das gebiet um das schwarze und
das social mehr und westwärts bis weit
nach südosteuropa hinein als ich möchte
mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr in die
geschichte vertiefen oder politische
oder religiöse diskussionen auslösen
denn oftmals ist es wirklich so dass
politik und religion uns alle spaltet
was ich sehr schade finde
aber das essen verbindet uns alle und
bei der türkischen küche ist es wirklich
so es waren einfach ganz ganz viele
verschiedene völker die wirklich ihre
fußspuren hier hinterlassen haben und
daher die küche ebenso abwechslungsreich
ist bei meiner familie ist es zb so
meine eltern sind weit aus der türkei
mein opa also der papa von meiner mama
da ist aber ein aussiedler und zwar aus
bulgarien decke hatte nämlich zu den
formaten und das war ein muslimisch
griechisch bulgarisches volk und airflow
eben in die türkei und setzte sich dann
in erzincan nieder
das heißt man sieht einfach von überall
her kamen die menschen in die türkei und
haben das tolle essen dort hinterlassen
mein papa hat es aus konya da gibt's das
tolle at lebte da habe ich auch ein
rezept in meinem buch und der mutter zum
beispiel der kommt aus zehn ob das ist
aus der schwarzmeerregion und da geht's
wirklich ganz ganz viele tolle rezepte
und da habe ich auch sein
lieblingsrezept in dem buch natürlich
aufgeschrieben und für euch ausprobiert
apropos gerichte ich denke wir sollten
bei unserem gericht weiter machen ich
habe jetzt nämlich inzwischen schon mal
die tomate und die paprika auch in feine
würfel geschnitten
ich habe versucht das buch so vielseitig
wie möglich zu gestalten und wirklich
ganz ganz viele rezepte auch für euch zu
machen
im buch findet ihr über 100 rezepte und
die habe ich aufgeteilt in verschiedene
kategorien
also da gibt es dann die kategorie
vorspeisen dieser unterteilt in kalte
und warme vorspeisen das ist einfach so
als kleinen appetitanreger für das
hauptgericht dann hat die kategorie
hauptgerichte mit fleisch und fisch da
sind wirklich ganz viele tolle und auch
sehr abwechslungsreiche rezepte zu
finden
hier findet ihr zb das rezept kann die
disk image und zwar ist es eine garnelen
pfanne also etwas was ich vor zwei
jahren wahrscheinlich noch nie
ausprobiert hätte
in der türkei habe ich aber dann das
erste mal garnelen gegessen und mich
sofort verliebt und deswegen musste
dieses rezept auf jeden fall mit rein
als nächstes natürlich auch dass keeper
prado also das jackett mit kever wovon
heute aber ich habe natürlich auch murat
fischpfanne drin also die fiskale die
seine mutter mir beigebracht hat richtig
originalrezept ausziehen und eins meiner
lieblingsrezepte von meiner mama das ist
das wasserbett also souverän
das ist wie so eine art lasagne nur eben
auf die türkische art und weise dann
nimmt man nämlich nudel blätter die
werden dann vorher ganz kurz in
salzwasser gegart und dann schön
geschichte als bürger also wirklich
super lecker ich habe natürlich auch
eine vegetarische kategorie und da
findet ihr einfach richtig tolle rezepte
wie zb gefüllte teigtaschen also böse
level das kennt ihr vielleicht auch auf
eurem türkei-urlaub das sitzen nämlich
ganz gerne mal die omas an der
straßenecke und haben davon touch also
so eine art offen und bereiten das
kurslevel nämlich ganz frisch so dann
gibt es natürlich auch die kategorie des
11 und teegebäck das spielt auch in der
türkischen küche eine ganz ganz wichtige
rolle
also wenn wir bei meiner familie sind
egal ob hier oder in der türkei
dann gibt's zur teezeit natürlich nicht
nur süßes wie zum beispiel baklava das
habe ich jetzt hier nicht mit drin weil
ich einfach baklava als ein zu
aufwendiges rezept empfinde als dass man
es wirklich jeden tag zu bereiten könnte
also habe ich hier rezepte herausgesucht
wie zb kümmere dass es auch eines meiner
lieblings rezepte im bereich des herz
hier gibt es aber zum beispiel auch die
doppelrolle oder auch espresso kekse die
wirklich super lecker sind aber zur
türkischen tee zeit gibt es nicht nur
süße rezepte sondern auch herzhaftes wie
zb den bulgur salat also christus was
man eben auch ganz gerne zur teezeit
reicht und was in diesem buch ganz
besonders ist das sind die menüs die ich
für euch vorbereitet habe und die findet
ihr ein
auch komplett verteilt im ganzen buch
und das sind dann immer - wo ich einfach
ein tolles hauptgericht habe eine
leckere beilage oder auch einmal einen
tipp dazu
und die sind wirklich auch sehr
abwechslungsreich das sind nicht nur
festtagsessen sondern auch wirklich
menüs die ihr jeden tag zubereiten
könnte als nächstes könnt ihr jetzt die
kartoffeln nehmen und alle gründlich
schälen und dann einmal abwaschen
ich habe ich jetzt die gewaschenen
kartoffeln und die werden jetzt fein
gehobelten ganz feine stifte damit sie
wirklich ganz ganz knusprig frittiert
werden können und da ist wirklich ein
feiner umso besser
ihr könnt entweder so noble leben ganz
normal so ein käse reiben oder das ganze
auch mit einer küchenmaschine machen mit
dem aufsatz ich mache das jetzt hier ich
drehe das ist einmal nämlich hier
komplett durch
[Musik]
die kartoffeln habe ich jetzt gerieben
und habe sie dann in ein geschirrtuch
eingewickelt in ein sauberes und habe
dann einfach den ganzen kartoffel saft
ausgedrückt so dass er wirklich schön
trocken sind und gleich beim frittieren
auch nicht so schäumen
hier habe ich schon mal das rät ihr fett
erhitzt und zwar auch mittel hoher hitze
in einem ganz großen topf das ist noch
nicht ganz der temperatur deswegen kann
ich jetzt hier mit dem ragout
weitermachen oder anfangen und zwar
kommt jetzt das butterschmalz in den
topf da könnt ihr jetzt so einen großen
topf nehmen oder einen weg zum beispiel
geht auch sehr gut und bei hoher stufe
erhitzen
zur feier des tages zur
buchveröffentlichung hat der murat den
top four poliert müsst ihr euch mal
vorstellen
er hat meine ganze koch geschichte aus
dem topf herausgelöst heute beginnen wir
also wieder bei null
und jetzt nehme ich das fleisch und das
brauche ich jetzt hier an wenn ihr nicht
so einen ganz großen topf vater macht
ihr das jetzt auch zwei funktionen ist
auch immer besser damit der topf nicht
so sein herunter herunterkühlt oder
könnt ihr das kurz scharf von allen
seiten anbraten und falls er jetzt
keinen rinderfilet habt oder akkus
können wir natürlich auch zum beispiel
hinterlassen nehmen
das ist ein bisschen günstiger und da
achtet ihr einfach drauf dass sie jetzt
keine szenen oder so mit drin habe damit
eben nicht da wird jetzt kurz von allen
seiten anbraten und dann nehme ich es
kurz heraus und wartet die zweite kostüm
auch an
und die zwischenzeit könnt ihr dann
immer nutzen um schon mal die kartoffeln
zu verzieren
das heißt sobald das fett die temperatur
hat das werde jetzt auch prüfen und zwar
stecke ich es einen schaschlikspieß
hinein und wenn sie dann ganz kleine
bläschen bilden dann ist die perfekte
temperatur beim fleisch anbraten ist
jetzt ganz wichtig dass das fleisch mit
zu kalt ist dh am besten nehmen
vor der verwendung etwa eine stunde
vorher aus dem kühlschrank damit
raumtemperatur annimmt und damit auch
richtig schön zart bleibt
[Musik]
ihr könnt es entweder das fleisch wieder
zurückgeben und gemeinsam mit den
zwiebeln anbraten
oder lasst es draußen so wie ich dann
bleibt mir nicht innen schön medium so
habe ich das ganz gerne
und jetzt nämlich die zwiebeln und den
knoblauch sehen und die werden jetzt im
übrigens fett angebraten und falls kein
fett mehr drinnen ist dann nehmt einfach
noch mal ein bisschen butter schmalz und
gibt dazu
und jetzt können die beschriebenen und
die knoblauch würzen etwa drei bis vier
minuten anbraten
[Musik]
also beim kartoffel frittieren müsst ihr
darauf achten dass sie schön trocken
sind und dass sie nicht so viele auf
einmal in das heiße fett gibt beim fehlt
natürlich auch aufpassen dass es nicht
hoch spritzt
denn wenn jetzt zu viel kalte massa ins
bett kommt dann scheint es auch und
läuft über ist mir nämlich auch schon
passiert und es ist gar nicht gut
sehr gefällig also ganz vorsichtig und
dann so lange frittieren bist du schön
knusprig sind also schön goldbraun
[Musik]
und ich spüre dann auch zwischendurch
immer so ein bisschen damit sie sich so
ein dinge voneinander lösen und die
schmecken später morath sowie die da
gibt's auch diese chips auf der packung
steht seit einem jahr gehabt wie
geschmack einer card macht nicht nur aus
wie die katholisch meckel was macht zum
auch die konsistenz also in bayern
bringt derweil nicht vor die motorik und
hätten die motorik wenn wir noch
brauchbar ist es doch an das mittel ist
der sensor die sensorik ok meine frau
machen dass die sensorik gelaufen und
ich hatte ganz anders nämlich ganz toll
ja richtig gut und passt auch perfekt
hier zum fleischgericht und die zwiebeln
gesetzt auch schön angebraten und es
riecht alles schon richtig lecker als
nächstes gebe ich hier jetzt die paprika
stücke und die tomaten mit rein und die
werden auch kurz mit angebraten so gut
und ich hab schon beide varianten
gemacht ich hab so einmal gemacht dass
ich das fleisch drin gelassen habt wird
auch super zart und richtig gut und das
zweite mal haben wir sie jetzt beim
kochkurs gemacht muratow wo das fleisch
innen dann noch richtig schön rosa war
das ist auch richtig gut
ich muss sagen ich habe es beim original
ein bisschen abgewandelt aus der türkei
und zwar hat mir dass dort ein oster
also ein meister am beigebracht das
rezept und er hat es so angerichtet und
die kartoffeln obendrüber das rack und
obendrauf ein flexi gut und ich fand es
dann ziemlich schade denn die knusprigen
kartoffeln sie wurden dann aufgeweicht
von diesem rackow und dann habe ich
gesagt ja dann ist es eigentlich
schwachsinnig das ganze zu frittieren
war dann kann man ja auch die kartoffeln
tempel und sich die kalorien fett sparen
also habe ich es umgedreht deswegen
heißt sie bringen auch karten also
türkei heißt auch so was wie abgesunken
ein gesuchter leben das dann sowieso ein
sinkt und deswegen habe ich jetzt anders
ich werde nämlich gleich die frage mit
dem joghurt auf dem teller anrichten und
das kartoffeln ist sozusagen oben drauf
und will ich mit so genial einem krampf
wir haben letzten sonntag in kokons noch
was soll er sonst samstag mit ganz toll
mir ganz tollen feld zur familie
ja und die waren einfach nur wie die
geister
andrews übrigens ein roman oder berlin
hatte julia und dann alle anderen die da
waren auch an die oma und so weiter also
für echt super lustig und wir haben das
selbst auch schon auf der ifa gemacht
dass der orden probiert und ich glaube
da gar nichts mehr dazu sagen
zwar verbessere die fans richtig cool
kannte er auch noch nicht
[Musik]
bundestag
und geht es eigentlich schneiden hat und
ja eigentlich schon als ich gab es die
meiste arbeit ist das portieren daher
sollte man das frittierfett auch voll
genug ansetzen und die kartoffeln immer
mal portionsweise verzieren
aber so insgesamt dauert nicht länger
als 20 minuten
na gut vielleicht noch mit zehn minuten
vorbereitet so besonderes sagt nun nicht
mehr kommen ganz andere geschmack genau
ich habe jetzt hier wie gesagt die
paprika stücke und tomaten mit drinnen
jetzt kommt ein bisschen brüder könnte
jetzt entweder fleischbrühe oder
gemüsebrühe nehmen
ich nehme jetzt einfach gemüsebrühe
meine selbstgemachte dadurch sehe ich es
aber sparsam weil ich ja noch salz und
die anderen gewürze habe und wie ist das
video gibt's schon das verlies minuten
genau das gibt es schon als video und es
wird aufgekocht und darf dann schön
einkochen und hier gebe ich jetzt auch
direkt die gewürze mit rein
gerade der kreuzkümmel der passt hier
perfekt
das ein bisschen einkochen lassen
und dann muss ich jetzt im prinzip nur
noch auf die kartoffeln warten
kreuzkümmel kühl gemeint ist die türkei
wirklich weit verbreitet ja ich muss
nochmal erzählen ja kann man schon
einmal machen ja schon mal erzählt was
sagt ein japaner wenn ein türke mich ja
jetzt bis dahin bekommen aber man muss
über sich selbst schon mal den tisch
einrichten und den tisch vorbereiten
können gleich gibt's essen soll ich
machen
[Musik]
und sobald die soße dann ein bisschen
reduziert ist könnte jetzt das fleisch
wieder dazu geben und dann kann es
einfach da drin so ein bisschen 10 also
ich lass das jetzt nur noch eine minute
etwa kochen oder kutteln und er kann das
fleisch darin ziehen und ist dann auch
echt perfekt die kartoffeln sind auch
gleich fertig das gericht kann gleich
serviert werden
und ich kann euch jetzt hier noch mal
ganz schnell das buch zeigen also was
mir sehr gut gefällt am buch morath ist
hier vorne der goldschmuck ist so schön
so richtig orientalisch mediterran
richtig cool was ich gemacht habe und
zwar sind das meine letzten drei bücher
also schwere kopf- hier einmal das
aktuelle das türkische mein ziel ist es
dass in der moderne und klassische
kuchen und torten es letztes jahr also
immerhin frühe aus kam letztes jahr
und zwischendrin dieses jahr haben wir
noch weit entfernt gemacht da sind
richtig coole rezepte für jeden tag drin
ganz einfache rezepte auch aber auch
sehr abwechslungsreich also ich glaube
viele unterschätzen das buch weil sie
denken das ist ein kinderbuch aber da
sind ganz ganz tolle rezepte drin
mittagessen frühstück das herz und so
weiter und dieses rezeptbuch da geht der
gesamte gewinn an oft gerade
sorgentelefon genau dieses video ist
eigentlich das wichtigste buch die usa
genau wohin das geld kommt und das ist
genau richtig gut dass nämlich ein
sorgentelefon vom bundesverband
kinderhospiz und ich habe einfach drauf
geachtet dass alle bücher alle bücher
die gleiche größe haben das heißt das
klassische als sally six und das
türkische kochbuch sind in etwa gleich
dick und das buch für oskar ist ein
bisschen dünner sind aber auch über 80
rezepte drin sind halt ein bisschen
einfacher
es ist ja ein schmerz der altlasten ja
um einiges günstiger
ja aber ich finde es echt schön morath
wenn du uns hätten ein regal bausch für
unser neues haus
da kann ich einfach die größe haben weil
alles sicher das problem ist dass die
die bücher nicht auf die regelgröße
genormt sind und dass wieder regal zu
klein sind aber schon bauen hast das
gewinnspiel leichen
ja genau das gewinnspiel das sprechen
wir jetzt noch kurz an und zwar bleiben
die eigentlich stehen
ich mache also das gewinnspiel wir sind
jetzt auch gleich mit unserem essen
fertig und ich glaube die jungs hinter
der kamera freuen sich schon richtig
drauf und das gewinnspiel geht es so
die fünf auf instagram und die fünf auf
facebook also insgesamt zehn personen
die als allererstes dieses rezept von
heute nachkochen plus einen zettel dazu
schreiben mit was soll draufstehen
liebsten verließ türkische küche und
genau das davor und dann so ein foto
machen so wie jetzt hier gleich
beschrieben 45 also die ersten fünf aus
instagram und auf facebook
ihr bekommt das türkische kochbuch
kostenlos zugeschickt ich werde
natürlich auch signieren für euch und ja
das mit dem zettel haben wir halt
gemacht damit es kein rezept was so
ähnlich war einfach schon mal pro woche
habe ich vor genau das heißt das ist
einfach fair ist für alle und deswegen
habe ich jetzt auch am ende des videos
erst erwähnt haben wir jetzt wirklich
alle sich an die regeln halten und haben
wir schauen einfach auf die uhrzeit und
schreiben euch an und ihr bekommt dann
das buch von uns kostenlos zugeschickt
bin jetzt nicht unbedingt dieses mal
schaffen könnten aufnehmen sobald oder
vegetarier ich will jetzt auch keine
vegetarier oder veganer ausschließen
dann könnt ihr einfach das ganze ohne
fleisch zubereiten und statt fleisch zum
beispiel champignons nehmen ich habe
auch im champignon laguna zu machen
ja also jeder darf mitmachen auf jeden
fall den zettel mit sallys türkische
küche dran ein foto machen und dann
hochladen und dann drücken wir euch
allen die daumen
im prinzip geht sitzt ja um
schnelligkeit aber ja und auch uns schön
anrichten das ist auch wichtig jetzt
warten wir noch auf die kartoffeln und
dann zeige ich euch wie ich das gericht
anrichte kombi crunchy diesen gott wie
engelshaar ich muss so lecker und die
muss man wissen was ja bei allen büchern
wichtig jetzt also bei den drei- und
auch genau bei dem bei dem allerersten
buch das ist einfach die rezepte alles
selber machen sieht aus wie ein baby
einfach unser baby projekt ja ich mache
alle dasselbe hier bei uns in der küche
das titelfoto hier zum beispiel das kann
man kurz erzählen
das titelfoto hier ist auch in unserer
wohnung entstanden
wir haben im esszimmer einfach mal kurz
tapeziert und haben ihnen die wände
gestaltet und den esstisch kennt er auch
da essen wir auch gleich und da haben
wir das foto auch alles bei uns in der
wohnung gemacht also echt cool und was
noch wichtiger ist dass wir das ganze
papier und auch der druck und so weiter
wird alles in deutschland gewinnen und
ist ganz viel das regionalgericht und
ruhig schön jedenfalls gibt es jetzt
gleich essen die kartoffeln sind gleich
fertig und crunchy dies sind probleme
ich habe jetzt schon bis gesalzen
richtig gut was ich jetzt nur noch
machen muss ist der basilikum den
schneide ich jetzt nämlich hier noch ins
fleisch wird rein und dann habe ich
alles fertig
[Musik]
also zuerst mal kommt ein klecks j dann
das ragout nebendran und der joghurt
also der muss sein modell dar und zwar
so sage ich immer ich nehme überall
joghurt aber das ist nämlich ein
zehnprozentiger ist wenn sie jahren ist
definitiv du hast ja interview
ja ich muss gleich weg ich finde mich
gleich bei der babybauch bemalung bei
der liefer genau waren meine mails
beantworten genau da wo kann ich dann
für euch da der brandort eure fragen bei
youtube facebook jetzt alles beantworten
naja und ließ damit gleiche überrascht
kriegt eine überraschungsparty aber das
weiß sie jetzt noch so jetzt weiß ich so
jetzt bin ich gerade dort ja und jetzt
die knusprigen kartoffeln und leckeres
kartoffeln lässt obendrauf
also wie gesagt nicht wie man schnell
erkannten grund hast sondern mittig
obendrauf
der anschluss richtig genial damit sie
krank bleiben
es ist jetzt nicht gerade und
kalorienarmes rezept außer wenn man die
kartoffeln weg lästern
aber es ist richtig lecker so du darfst
jetzt gerne schon mal probieren und ich
kann euch jetzt erzählen wo ist das buch
überhaupt gibt jetzt fragen
wahrscheinlich alle menschen gibt es
denn dieses buch mit den tollen
türkischen rezepten
das gibt es ab heute bei uns im online
shop als of sales shop.de und demnächst
gibt es auch im handel also bei globus
und bei intersport österreich es war ein
einziges ist premiere
intersport aber ich kenne januar
wir müssen erstmal ausliefern die sind
ja noch gerade aus der druckerei
gekommen und online gibt es wie gesagt
nur bei uns weil wir einfach mit amazon
zum beispiel nicht zusammenarbeiten und
die meine bücher nicht bekommen
es kam auch schon mal so sagen oder
bitteschön morath okay probier mal auch
wenn was auch wichtig ist und vielleicht
auch mal anschreit
das ist einfach gleich weggehauen als
ich einmal ein leibgericht ehrliche
lecker ich lieb dich so sehr und dann so
kartoffeln und ist jetzt mich gespannt
wird
wirst du eher schwächer ich probiere
gleich dann schaffe ich zwischen den
zähen ringen
ich bin auch mal gespannt da für fotos
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß und viel
glück beim gewinnspiel und ich hoffe
dass ich das video gefallen hat und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder biss
dann geschmacks wahrscheinlich richtig
lecker aber nicht nur dieses rezept
sondern auch alle anderen im bogen
kommt jungs essen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr zeit und lust habt können
sie mich gerne am 7 oktober am samstag
von 12 bis 14 uhr im globus in grünstadt
besuchen da habe ich nämlich meine
signierstunde da machen wir gemeinsam
fotos und ich kann eure bücher signieren
und ich freue mich schon mal für euch
bis dann tschüss